it has never been more beneficial to be
a good person than it is right now
because the shadows of our society are
being exposed by the distribution of
communication what am i doing right now
they're going to stay on track got a lot
going on stuff blog
what's up WT Clark high school big
shout-out to Samir hope you're
representing Vayner proper my man two
seconds for all the high school kids
listen you're young and that's your
strengths and your weakness right first
and foremost the weakness like you
haven't accomplished [ __ ] I don't know
if you better beat that because I'm sure
you're not gonna let it play in high
school but edit it beep it him
accomplished [ __ ] and and you've got the
audacity like you have on the flip side
that's your strength you're young and
you got your whole life in front of you
and all of you trying to prove yourself
put yourself on have stuff and that's
gonna make you impatient please
recognize how young you are and get real
real real patient and last of all find
that thing whether it's eSports and
video games whether it's basketball
whether it's painting or writing people
are gonna tell you it's not practical
but it is find your passion and go deep
put in 18 hours of work don't lay on the
couch and go through your Instagram feed
put in the work find your passion know
that you're young which means you're
impatient but you've got nothing but
time you know I think that's a great
question I think there's a couple things
that run through my mind number one I
love that the Internet has eliminated
the truth behind a man's world you know
now I am not naive and I don't want to
come across tone-deaf I'm the first and
have been for long before it was popular
like it sure seems now like everybody's
different there are clearly advantages
for being a white male in America versus
a female versus a minority versus being
born in Iran that like that's just real
life I think the bigger part and I was
an early investor in Birchbox and
Mi'kmaq and Brit Co and you know I'm
I've to be very frank have done
quite well with my female
entrepreneurial ventures because they've
been underpriced in cost because it has
been a man's world in VC land and there
has been a disrespect of the female
entrepreneur and I'm not mother Teresa
or this amazing human being I'm just a
businessman I'm like they would never
cross my mind to think that a woman or
an alien or a Latino it couldn't do it
as well and so in a weird way I think I
took advantage of the shortcomings of a
lot of white males and it was mainly on
the back of knowing that the internet
doesn't give a [ __ ] who you are
my thesis that I wrote and crush it and
the Thank You economy has played out
which is the internet doesn't care
everybody's got a shot you're more than
welcome to go on Twitter and CNN and
dwell from 7:00 p.m. to 11 p.m. and [ __ ]
on everybody and call people out and and
be upset and say this one's bad and this
one's good how about instead of those
four hours dwelling in the muck of all
this realizing that what it means is
this is the greatest opportunity ever
for anybody and everybody because if as
long as you have this and I get emails
from people that are homeless every
single day of my life who have this this
is an unlock we need perspective like
everybody's on their [ __ ] high horse
and judging for every entrepreneur
that's listening right now go on the
offense what do I say make that woman
chip on your shoulder get real big and
use it as a driver of positivity and
opportunity not looking backwards
whenever you are being the best version
of what you are is always going to be
the right strategy and I think we need
to talk more about self-awareness the
secret sauce is don't overcomplicate
stuff you have to work hard you have to
work smart you have to be empathetic and
grateful you have to be positive and
optimistic and everything that you're
not every time you're not you're giving
points off the board you don't have to
be optimistic maybe you're born
pessimistic but please understand that
will detrimental II hurt you in your
ambitions of if you want to be an
entrepreneur because it takes blind
optimism because everything in your face
every day is telling you no and you're
completely completely committed to yes
hello Gary can see me now I got to do to
you
the tide is turning I'm in control I'm
worried about this real energy coming
from you yeah I'm excited
okay I'm in control Gary yes sir okay
we're gonna do this I'm gonna do it to
you man I'm listening okay stop what I'm
trying to do is to help you all
understand what the best principles of
winners aren't they they're winning
because they're doing things they're
operating by recipes and senses they're
doing those things over and over that
makes them winners
okay so Gary is a winner and now we're
gonna get into Gary's principles here we
go here we go what do you think you're
going after where did it come from
my intuition on this and I do think I
spend a lot of time on it is I feel like
I'm going after all-time legacy I think
that it comes from a mix of guilt
gratitude insecurities and optimism
because I was such a poor student at
such a young age
me too and because I wasn't a good
athlete in any shape or form it
eliminated the two things that boys were
judged on when I grew up either you were
the student going to Harvard or you were
tremendous athlete and going to USC I
was neither entrepreneurship was surely
not cool in 1984 five six and seven so
what I was doing off the field or out of
school was making money but that wasn't
deemed as a merit or a remarkable act I
hear you and so that void of the
intellectual is then also what your debt
100% great
I am completely driven by a chip on my
shoulder on my upbringing except that I
am empathetic to everybody else so it's
not manifesting as a negative it's
manifesting as a positive boy you're
doing a good job man okay it's going
good
tell me about those
those that you think would be helpful
that have helped you no question I am an
unbelievable buyer and I think I mostly
underestimated great in the capitalistic
game is empathy empathy will give you
leverage with the other party boom
there's a principle but because of
empathy and it is my binary Northstar
i-ight temper my expectations of others
on my team and trying to be realistic to
their realities okay watching others
with a lot of freedom gives me context
of how to put them in the best position
to succeed insecurity will lead to
undermining actions that hurt the merit
of your organization I am dumbfounded by
people positioning themselves and their
businesses as if life is a sprint when
it is clearly a marathon I'm devastated
that people make short-term financial
decisions to buy something that closes
is a short-term gap in their insecurity
and at the undermining of their
long-term wealth and happiness okay
having the humility to carry to opposing
points of view and making them rub up
against that's another one we're gonna
split that okay I've got principle four
days kids okay you know having the
humility to be able to have you know
have humility in being able to carry
opposing views on an issue and then
creating friction and making a judgement
in the context of the moment failure is
tremendous I'm wearing a New York Jets
Christmas sweater not a New York Yankees
quick Christmas sweater and at six years
old I passionately cared about those
there's deep insight into my love affair
with the Jets and the mix they have tell
me in the failure now follow that
through what do you I prefer I prefer
the journey over the riches my personal
wealth is disproportionately being
sabotaged by myself because I enjoy the
process of gathering in it I literally
think is somewhere
it's smart because you're not off the
mines you're out look what you're doing
is you're realizing what really has
value okay and money the born of the
challenges of money is it's easy to
count and because it's easy to count
then people sort of say I count it up
and I got more of that and that's the
thing of the success if you can have
happiness points if you could count
happiness I'm winning we would optimize
for happiness and you'd ever been so
what you're doing is optimizing for
happiness
you're not optimizing for money that's a
lot smarter there are so much more
upside on both legacy and wealth when
you make it about legacy
especially compounded in what people do
very poorly here's a principle people
are very bad at understanding the new
context of communication and they're
deploying old principles on new playing
fields it has never been more beneficial
to be a good person than it is right now
because the shadows of our society are
being exposed by the distribution of
communication owning your shortcomings
and bringing awareness to them is
disproportionate strength and leverage
in the long term boom which is exposing
your own shortcomings morally
intellectually everything exposing your
own shortcomings is this proportionate
strength and leverage in our society
did you see eight-mile the Eminem movie
no I want you to and I mean it well but
only because I want you to see the last
battle rap because in the last battle
rap Eminem rap instead of making fun of
the other guy which is the framework of
the game of battle rap yeah I have a
soda battle love it he he made fun of
himself the entire time leaving the
other person nothing
relationships 5149 give 51% of the value
of the relationship see the other person
and figure out how to maximize the four
this was good thank you great so much
thank you everyone
[Music]
person that can make America or the
world give a [ __ ] about things that they
don't give a [ __ ] about yet is going to
win this new world we need to make
people in the world care about the human
beings behind these sports not hoping
pickleball gets popular somewhat but
looking at the current state of
pickleball and saying holy [ __ ] there's
this LeBron or holy [ __ ] there's the
Andre Agassi of pickleball and we're
gonna turn him into a vine 2.0 snapchat
Instagram star because that's where the
leverage sits I think that's the Machine
you need to build the propaganda human
machine compliment to the stars of the
47 sub sports that you're going to try
to create now we've got something
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey are you filming blog real quick just
a great moment just happened literally
Kyle's been dressed up ridiculously been
filming all day dumb [ __ ] stuff that had
no shot we just have the moment of the
episode and he's got the camera like
sticking into his like thigh cow the
whole purpose of filming everything is
knowing that at any moment I can throw
out the haymaker that changes the course
of one's life are you alright what's
going on here what's this meeting about
how are you good headed in the airport
yeah I'm sure nice to meet you such a
pleasure man we were just talking Eliot
[Applause]
and then he's doing cool things with the
fans like when put me on to where he's
like he told all the kids like yo play
my new song over the intercom yours and
I'll feature you that's what's up so if
he did that and he's doing hacking like
what you were talking about with dunk
then you're gonna win because you have
actual music pound that I already know
and then the only other part that
matters is distribution and you you are
naturally it comes natural to you a hack
distribution I always talk about the
example of P Diddy going on TRL or when
I wear Christmas sweaters courtside at
basketball games it's just understanding
what's gonna get you hurt the end yeah
it's only two things is it good enough
come on people [ __ ] hear it straight
up you know what's amazing about you
youngsters you guys are coming with so
much more entrepreneurial savvy than the
crew that came before you everybody's
trying to be a mogul out here it's cool
it's good man that's how that's how you
really win dollars are more interesting
than sins and everybody was settling for
cents you know everybody was selling
settling for cents and then puffs and
jay-z and Birdman those guys deserve a
lot of credit they started to create a
framework
so good makes me happy man good for you
how old are you that's what's up
yeah man there's anything I can help you
with you let me know music in the vlog
like if you want to like like I my
number one recommendation the same thing
you're doing with kids in school go hard
after YouTube vloggers and get your
music in their [ __ ] vlogs it's the
number one you get Jake and Paul to put
your amusing song or KC or and by the
way those are the ones just I know them
and they're big there's [ __ ] a
hundred thousand bloggers collaborations
in your music to not not up but wide let
me explain not sitting here be like oh
[ __ ] we got to do something with what
you mean or 21 sad or something like
that post my like no ken well that's
what I'm going are there people in the
country or pop or jazz that are coming
up like you to that you just like their
flavor or I thought logic did it right
like or just in culture what [ __ ]
auto-tune even Boyd could sound good
like what if somebody's just winning in
life baby Arielle just put out music
like I don't know it just feels like
almost anybody can get in the game in
certain ways with the technology
advances in post-production so just
being smart you know like like Russell
Westbrook - like some girl that's got 19
million followers on unsnap I give you a
good piece of advice be patient
that's the only thing that that's your
kryptonite right now you got you clearly
had your [ __ ] together the only thing
that's gonna [ __ ] you up
is cuz you know it's gonna happen you
can feel it and sometimes youngsters are
just like [ __ ] why hasn't it happened
like 13 months from now like happened
like that song that completely changed
[ __ ] and then they start doing short
cuts signing with somebody dumb doing
the clab with somebody dumb talking
about something they don't believe in
just because they think it will make a
song popular they deviate this next
chapter is the most important one this
is the one that decides everything it's
easy to stay down when there's nothing
to go up to
but when you're on the cusp that's it's
what I do it's hard like I'm [ __ ] by
one but I'm trying to win the whole
[ __ ] thing so I'm just eating [ __ ]
still 100 might steal your hoodie your
beanie yeah I don't think I have to I
have one was this mine or yours
originally now it's mine but you're
disappointed because he was just kind of
weirdly borrowing it and then you're
gonna have it no I need more beanies
guys this is me you don't want me to do
that you want me to make a beanie
situation right but then totally other
beanie situation let me put all the
aspiring entrepreneurs that are trying
to build look at baller look at these
look right like what do you think we're
doing here we're putting people on
[ __ ] hustles send me some [ __ ]
beanies and I'll wear them cuz Tyler's
not my [ __ ] boss and when I come out
with a beanie collaboration with a huge
brand like caseless huge meaning I can
refurbish it or it's [ __ ] huge call
me [ __ ] adidas until I have a [ __ ]
beanie deal or start my own being
[ __ ] beanie which we've tried to
start a year ago and didn't I'm gonna
give to my community and put people on
and get exposure for them is that okay
with you Tyler to sell something they're
passionate about so it feels like a
hobby and not a business do not run
after the money right don't go after
sneakers or slime or or support your
iPhone cases because that's where the
money is sell something around an elf
costume or or Smurfs or Captain Crunch
cereal because you love it big aside
hustles sign hustles record their
passion because you're already tired
from your real job and so we're gonna do
something from 8 p.m. to 4:00 in the
morning well it might as well be the
same thing that you would have watched
the movie of or played you know whether
it's soccer or video games or just your
side also has to be
completely completely tied to your
passion otherwise you won't have the
energy to succeed
definitely not I'm not doing the
behavior yet to buy the Jets but you
know 2038
it feels good if you're working on the
[ __ ] the project the plane project
did you guys watch me watching videos
yet did you did you call don't lie hello
has a team have you guys watched the
videos because three people haven't have
you watched them have you don't lie can
you guys watch them please thank you
such a pleasure
what a man I love it man tell me seinem
yeah trying to make that side how some
money are you gonna wear smart that
long-term investment I'm very well but
you might want to put this in your
office I mean it was uh it was a is that
Larry Bird slapping me do what you smack
you
Oh my end of the fight Ray Dalio now yo
Ray Dalio 3 p.m. at the flagpole
[ __ ] this hello hello so a couple great
things happen with me tossing Wi-Fi
yesterday I my flight home number one I
created a new a new version of making an
album it's called 13 rants in a row I'll
be launching that on Tuesday
I'm not joking I'm super excited about
it it's gonna I think it's not gonna
work but I'm excited that I'm doing it
and this and I finished that in time by
the way this is literally what happened
nope the Wi-Fi was broken I went to
sleep right away because I'm something
like 48 hours but it was so new that I
had to do work and get some answers for
everybody that I spooked myself after an
hour and woke up then tried to get on
Wi-Fi for 30 minutes looked at the map
and when you're close to the North Pole
sometimes it doesn't work then they told
me it was broken I got pissed then I
crushed my email that was in there as
you guys are some of you got that then I
thought four hours so I decide you know
what [ __ ] and I deserve it let me watch
a movie I watched the Tupac movie right
I watched the Tupac movie and get so
inspired I decide to literally and meets
it's like I cried in one video
d-roc you shut the parenting one is
crazy did you cry a little there's a
video that can get 50 million on
Facebook if it hits right about like
just asking parents to stop imposing
their insecurities on their kids like
just really good [ __ ] you know like four
or five minutes not my normal minute
ramps they're long and like anyway this
is a pretty surprise
it's like a private pre-party you guys
are pre-gaming I like you guys arbitrage
I get it you guys are flaunting out how
to go of course the artist yeah yes
you're all one well to get the [ __ ] out
of here yeah she's super sweet she's in
the office today I don't think you were
here right I think she's gonna be a star
yeah
always been like like that go get her
entrepreneur like I post blimpy foreign
pilots she's uh I really like her I
think she's got a real shot yeah it's
cool I'll see you guys there I don't see
you have a great holiday we will see all
right cool I love love how you're
formulating your thoughts throughout and
I'm trying to like go ahead yeah listen
moldable dictatorship it's very raw so
raw that you don't think you can do as
well as it can if we do something else
when you have already thought about them
and you're trying them out onto me and
you're testing them out this mess yeah
correct and I know the energy that you
had on it I know it I know you had the
energy of like you need to like get this
to them but you were just formulating
your thoughts great and I love that no I
don't think we need 45 minutes
I think you're wrong we do what you are
saying all the time you have to have an
off-speed pitch to set up your fastball
even if the project doesn't succeed it's
a success I understand listen I remember
like you listen guys this is amazing you
understand it so I for sure don't think
it's gonna go viral no no I'm just
talking I can't wait to hear it and he
says I want it this way because I think
of things as a holistic thing not in the
silo words right guess what you just
[ __ ] record it again yeah no I know
so dear [ __ ] fans do you want these
11 tracks do they definitely definitely
videos yes we want video audio and the
written word I listen I totally get it
if you think of it in the micro I think
the macro of it is what helps the
overall that's when do you run an hour
target basically he's like some of it's
hard to watch just busier for me then I
was like that's interesting nobody's
ever seen that from one that's why like
that's that's how we did not it was like
that's his whole theory about everything
great news great news
literally hey everybody that's how we
thought about launching this project
here's your intro to the [ __ ] plane
project I hope you enjoy it
company ID class have your company IDs
oh you're not sure it's a memo you can't
be Madison the chips don't bother
anybody
good thank you brother do not let this
guy in the Red Hat in thank you
[Music]
it's only one it's either sink or swim
can't hold back you can't expect to win
gonna go harder oh you've gotta learn
don't suppress your fire baby let it
burn nobody can take
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
nobody can
[Music]
[Applause]